- Bienvenue dans Comprendre l'information et le calcul quantiques.
Je m'appelle John Watrous et je suis directeur technique pour
l'éducation chez IBM Quantum.
C'est la septième leçon de la série et dans cette leçon nous allons aborder le problème d'estimation de phase et comment on peut le résoudre
avec un ordinateur quantique.
Nous allons ensuite appliquer l'estimation de phase au problème de la factorisation des entiers, dont nous avons parlé dans la leçon précédente.
Ce qu'on va obtenir, c'est l'algorithme de Shor, qui permet de factoriser des entiers à coût polynomial ou en temps polynomial si on préfère
penser en termes de temps nécessaire plutôt que du nombre d'opérations élémentaires dont on a besoin.
C'est le joyau de la couronne des algorithmes quantiques en quelque sorte, et même si la factorisation de grands entiers
peut avoir une utilité limitée pour la plupart des gens, ça reste l'une des preuves les plus convaincantes dont on dispose pour l'hypothèse que les ordinateurs quantiques offriront des avantages frappants
sur les ordinateurs classiques. Voici un aperçu de la leçon.
On va commencer par une définition du problème d'estimation de phase lui-même, puis on va discuter d'une méthode pour résoudre ce problème
avec un ordinateur quantique.
On va procéder étape par étape, en commençant par ce que tu peux
considérer comme une sorte d'échauffement.
Dans le problème d'estimation de phase, l'objectif est d'approximer
un certain nombre réel et dans cette partie d'échauffement
on va voir comment on peut obtenir
une approximation très basse précision de ce nombre.
Ça ne va pas être
suffisant pour la factorisation quand on applique notre solution au
problème d'estimation de phase à la factorisation des entiers,
on va en fait avoir besoin d'une approximation assez haute précision, mais ça reste utile de commencer par ce genre d'échauffement
juste pour avoir une idée de
comment tout ça fonctionne.
On va ensuite aborder la question de comment obtenir plus de précision, ce qui va mener très
naturellement à une opération connue sous le nom de transformée de Fourier quantique.
On va voir exactement ce qu'est cette opération et comment elle peut être implémentée
avec un circuit quantique.
Et une fois qu'on l'a, on va pouvoir l'appliquer
à l'estimation de phase pour obtenir une procédure générale pour résoudre le problème
avec très haute précision.
Puis dans la dernière partie de la leçon, on va voir comment une solution au
problème d'estimation de phase nous permet de factoriser des entiers efficacement.
Et spécifiquement ce qu'on va obtenir, c'est l'algorithme de Shor pour
la factorisation des entiers, ou du moins quelque chose d'équivalent à l'algorithme de Shor.
La façon dont ça fonctionne, c'est qu'on se donne essentiellement un tremplin, qui est encore un autre problème appelé le problème de recherche d'ordre.
Et en particulier on va voir comment on peut résoudre le problème de recherche d'ordre en utilisant la procédure d'estimation de phase, puis on va voir comment
on peut factoriser des entiers
en résolvant le problème de recherche d'ordre. On va commencer par un cas particulier d'un théorème appelé le théorème spectral,
et spécifiquement on va se concentrer sur ce que le théorème nous dit
pour les matrices unitaires.
Le théorème spectral est
un théorème très important de l'algèbre linéaire et
de l'analyse fonctionnelle.
Il nous dit quelque chose d'intéressant sur la façon dont certaines applications linéaires peuvent être exprimées sous une certaine forme, souvent appelée une
décomposition spectrale,
ce qui est utile pour de nombreuses raisons.
Et comme je l'ai dit, on va se concentrer sur ce que ce théorème nous dit
pour les matrices unitaires.
Le théorème spectral est
plus général que ça. Il ne fonctionne pas pour toutes les matrices, mais il fonctionne pour une classe de matrices
appelées matrices normales, qui incluent toutes les matrices unitaires ainsi que certaines matrices
qui ne sont pas unitaires.
Mais juste pour garder les choses simples, on va restreindre notre attention
aux matrices unitaires pour l'instant parce que c'est tout ce dont on a besoin pour
les besoins de cette leçon.
Voici un énoncé du théorème spectral juste pour les matrices unitaires.
Supposons que U est une
matrice unitaire N par N.
Ce que le théorème dit
c'est qu'il doit exister une base orthonormale de
vecteurs, psi un à psi N,
avec N nombres complexes
Lambda un à Lambda N, tous situés sur le cercle unité complexe, de telle sorte que U peut être exprimé
comme on l'a dans cette équation.
C'est ce qu'on appelle une décomposition spectrale de U, comme je l'ai déjà mentionné, et ça peut être très pratique de savoir que U peut être écrit de cette façon.
Il peut parfois être pratique d'avoir ces vecteurs et ces nombres quand on travaille avec
une matrice unitaire particulière U, et ça peut aussi être très
utile de savoir simplement
qu'une telle expression est toujours possible comme façon de prouver certaines choses sur les matrices unitaires par exemple.
Dans cet énoncé du théorème, chacun de ces nombres,
Lambda un à lambda N, est écrit d'une façon particulière
comme E à la puissance deux pi I fois theta où chacun des thetas
theta un à theta N est un nombre réel, et
on va revenir sur cette façon
d'écrire chacun de ces
nombres dans un petit moment.
Une chose importante à remarquer
à propos de ces vecteurs et de ces nombres, c'est que chaque vecteur psi
K doit être un vecteur propre de la matrice U avec
la valeur propre correspondante lambda K.
Ce qui signifie que si on
multiplie psi K par U, ce qu'on obtient c'est lambda K fois psi K.
Donc ce que U fait à chacun de ces vecteurs, c'est simplement de le multiplier par le nombre correspondant lambda K.
En général pour un vecteur quelconque arbitraire, ce ne sera pas comme ça que U fonctionne, mais les vecteurs propres sont spéciaux.
Et ce que le théorème nous dit, c'est qu'il existe en fait
une base orthonormale de ces vecteurs propres.
Cette équation en bas, soit dit en passant, découle de l'expression qu'on a pour U d'après le théorème, combinée avec le fait que
les vecteurs sont orthonormaux.
WEBVTT
Si tu multiplies
l'expression de U par n'importe quel psi K et que tu utilises l'orthonormalité des vecteurs, tu obtiendras une somme dans laquelle
tous les termes sont zéro
sauf un d'entre eux, et le seul terme qu'il nous reste ressemble à ça.
On peut maintenant définir le
problème d'estimation de phase.
Le problème est un peu
inhabituel comme on va le voir.
On nous donne deux choses. Premièrement, on nous donne la description d'un circuit quantique unitaire,
qui agit sur N qubits
pour un certain choix de N, et quand on dit que c'est
un circuit unitaire,
on veut simplement dire que tous
les gates sont unitaires, donc il n'y a pas de mesures
dans ce circuit.
Deuxièmement, on nous donne un état psi à N qubit, et c'est la partie inhabituelle.
On a en fait un
état quantique en entrée pour ce problème, et c'est une seule copie de cet état.
Pour tous les autres problèmes de calcul dont on a parlé dans cette série, l'entrée a été classique, soit sous la forme d'une chaîne
de bits ou d'une boîte noire.
Et ce n'est pas surprenant parce que les
problèmes de calcul qu'on rencontre dans notre vie quotidienne ont tendance à être classiques,
parce que ce sont les
problèmes qui nous intéressent le plus.
La façon dont tu peux
penser à ce problème, c'est que c'est quelque chose qui apparaît ou est susceptible d'apparaître comme un sous-problème.
Et la procédure d'estimation de phase qu'on va finalement obtenir est quelque chose qu'on
utilise généralement comme une sous-routine
dans un calcul plus grand, vraisemblablement un pour un problème classique
qui nous intéresse.
Maintenant, ça va être un problème à promesse et l'état psi n'est pas
n'importe quel vieil état quantique.
On nous promet que psi est un vecteur propre de quelle que soit l'opération unitaire U que le circuit donné décrit.
Et l'objectif est de trouver ou
d'approximer la valeur propre qui correspond au vecteur propre psi.
Énonçons le problème de façon
un peu plus précise.
L'entrée consiste en un
circuit quantique unitaire sur N qubits, qui peut être encodé comme une chaîne de bits
en utilisant la méthode qu'on préfère pour encoder les descriptions de circuits quantiques, avec un état psi à N qubit.
On peut appeler le circuit comme on veut, mais ce qui compte vraiment en termes d'énoncé de ce problème, c'est l'opération unitaire elle-même
qui est effectuée quand le circuit est exécuté, et cette opération unitaire
est décrite par la matrice U.
Mais on ne nous donne pas U sous forme de matrice, on nous donne juste la description d'un circuit quantique qui implémente U.
La promesse, comme je l'ai déjà indiqué, c'est que psi est un vecteur propre de U.
Donc si on exécutait notre circuit sur psi, on obtiendrait psi en sortie multiplié par quelle que soit la valeur propre,
ce qui serait une phase globale
dans cette situation.
Et finalement, la sortie du problème est une approximation de la valeur propre correspondant à psi, et spécifiquement on cherche
une approximation du nombre réel theta, entre zéro et un, en incluant
zéro, mais en n'incluant pas un
qui satisfait l'équation
qu'on a à l'écran.
Pour expliquer cette façon de
paramétrer la valeur propre correspondant à pis, et aussi pour clarifier ce qu'on entend par approximation,
dessinons une image du
cercle unité complexe.
On peut placer les nombres un, I,
moins un, et moins I à leurs emplacements habituels et on peut considérer
un point quelconque arbitraire sur le
cercle paramétré par theta comme on l'a dans l'énoncé du problème.
C'est le point qu'on
obtient si on commence à un et qu'on tourne d'un angle de
deux fois pi fois theta, donc l'angle n'est pas
theta, c'est deux pi theta,
et une autre façon d'y penser, c'est que si on commence à un et qu'on parcourt une distance de deux pi theta sur le cercle lui-même,
on arrivera à notre point, E à la
puissance deux fois pi fois theta.
Chaque point du cercle unité complexe peut être représenté de cette façon
pour un choix unique de theta.
Et c'est parce qu'on fait
tout le tour du cercle quand theta passe de zéro à un, et si on allait jusqu'à
theta égal un,
on serait de retour là où on
a commencé à theta égal zéro, c'est pourquoi on inclut zéro, mais on n'inclut pas un.
Juste pour s'assurer que chaque
point du cercle unité complexe corresponde à une valeur unique de theta dans la plage qu'on considère.
Il y a diverses façons
dont on pourrait imaginer approximer une valeur particulière de theta, mais la façon dont on va le faire, c'est d'approximer theta avec une fraction,
où le dénominateur
est deux à la puissance M pour un certain choix d'un entier positif M, et le numérateur est un entier y
entre zéro et deux à la M moins un.
Tu peux penser à ça comme une approximation à m bits de theta si tu veux, et on pourrait écrire ce
nombre en notation binaire
où on a un point binaire suivi de la représentation binaire de Y.
Je dis point binaire soit dit en passant
plutôt que point décimal parce que décimal signifie base 10 et je parle de base deux
ici, mais c'est la même idée.
Mais de toute façon on peut
aussi simplement le considérer comme une fraction comme il
apparaît à l'écran.
Et pour être clair, quand on pense aux
approximations dans ce contexte, il faut comprendre
que les valeurs de theta
WEBVTT
proches de zéro et les valeurs de theta proches de un sont en fait proches l'une de l'autre.
Donc par exemple, si theta est égal à 0,99 et qu'on approxime cette valeur
de theta par la valeur zéro,
alors c'est une assez bonne approximation dans le sens où c'est
à moins d'un centième de la valeur réelle, quand
on fait le tour du cercle
et qu'on revient à zéro quand on arrive à un.
Le terme modulo un est parfois utilisé pour décrire la situation, où on
assimile essentiellement theta égal un à theta égal zéro.
Le point est qu'on s'intéresse vraiment à l'emplacement du point
E à la puissance deux pi I theta sur le cercle unité,
et penser à cette
façon d'approximer theta a du sens quand on a cet objectif en tête.
L'énoncé du problème lui-même,
tel qu'il apparaît à l'écran, ne précise pas à quel point l'approximation de theta doit être bonne,
mais c'est quelque chose qu'on peut ajuster selon nos besoins.
Dans certaines situations on pourrait se contenter d'une approximation basse précision
de theta, et dans d'autres situations on pourrait exiger
une approximation très haute précision, et l'énoncé du problème lui-même
peut être affiné en conséquence.
Ensuite on va voir comment on peut résoudre
le problème d'estimation de phase avec un ordinateur quantique et
on va commencer par un échauffement.
Ce ne sera pas notre solution finale
au problème.
Ce qu'on va faire, c'est d'utiliser le phénomène de rétroaction de phase pour essayer d'apprendre quelque chose
sur la valeur propre correspondant à un vecteur propre donné.
Rappelle-toi que dans le
problème d'estimation de phase on nous donne la description
d'un circuit quantique unitaire pour une opération U quelconque,
et ce qu'on fait d'abord, c'est d'utiliser cette description de circuit pour créer un nouveau circuit qui implémente une opération U contrôlée comme
c'est représenté à l'écran.
C'est assez simple à faire. Ce qu'on peut faire, c'est d'ajouter un qubit de contrôle, qui est représenté en
haut dans ce diagramme
et d'utiliser ce nouveau qubit
de contrôle comme contrôle pour chaque gate unique qui
apparaît dans notre circuit.
Donc tous les gates sont appliqués si ce qubit de contrôle est mis à un, et aucun d'eux n'est appliqué si le qubit de contrôle est mis à zéro,
ce qui signifie qu'on va
avoir besoin d'une version contrôlée de chaque gate qui
apparaît dans le circuit U, mais on n'a pas besoin de penser
à ces nouveaux gates contrôlés
comme des gates simples si on ne le veut pas. Ils pourraient être implémentés
comme de petits circuits faits de gates issus de n'importe quel ensemble de gates
qu'on a choisi d'utiliser. Et une fois qu'on a une
version contrôlée de U, on peut envisager d'exécuter ce circuit,
où on met d'abord le qubit de contrôle dans une superposition de zéro et un, on applique le gate U contrôlé au vecteur propre qu'on nous a donné,
puis on applique un gate Hadamard
au contrôle et on mesure.
On va voir pourquoi il est logique de faire ça en passant à travers l'analyse, mais même avant d'arriver aux détails, on peut immédiatement voir une similarité
avec l'algorithme de Deutsch par exemple, où on applique
quelques gates Hadamard et on mesure comme façon
d'effectivement sonder
ce que fait une opération donnée ici.
C'est un unitaire contrôlé
plutôt qu'un gate de requête, mais il y a des idées très similaires en jeu.
Voyons donc ce que fait le circuit.
L'état initial est le vecteur propre psi, mis en produit tensoriel avec l'état zéro
pour le qubit de contrôle,
l'application du premier gate Hadamard transforme l'état du
qubit du haut en un état plus et on peut développer tout
l'état comme c'est montré ici.
On applique ensuite l'opération U contrôlée et ce qu'elle fait, c'est d'appliquer U à psi quand le qubit de contrôle est mis à un,
mais pas quand il est mis à zéro. Donc on obtient l'état pi deux
qui est écrit à l'écran.
On peut simplifier l'état
en utilisant le fait que psi est un vecteur propre de U avec la valeur propre e à la puissance deux pi I theta.
Donc on obtient que cette valeur propre multiplie le deuxième
terme, mais pas le premier.
Et on peut simplifier en utilisant la bilinéarité
du produit tensoriel.
Donc ce qu'on a ici, c'est le
phénomène de rétroaction de phase, mais cette fois ça se passe pour un vecteur propre quelconque psi d'une opération unitaire quelconque U,
par opposition à une opération NOT appliquée à un
état moins plus spécifiquement.
Voilà donc l'état après l'application de l'opération U contrôlée.
Soit dit en passant, ça vaut la peine
de prendre un moment pour remarquer que l'état des N qubits du bas est toujours le vecteur propre psi.
Ce qui est formidable parce que ça
nous donne l'opportunité de l'utiliser à nouveau si on le choisit.
Ensuite le deuxième gate Hadamard est appliqué et voici l'état qu'on obtient.
Et je n'ai pas montré tous les
détails de la dérivation ici, mais si tu appliques le
gate Hadamard et que tu simplifies, c'est ce que tu devrais obtenir.
Voilà donc l'état juste
avant la mesure.
On peut donc se concentrer sur cet état pour voir ce qu'on peut apprendre
sur theta en mesurant.
Et si on mesure le qubit du
haut ou le qubit le plus à droite, voici les probabilités qu'on obtient pour les deux résultats.
Et ici j'ai utilisé quelques
formules de base qui relient les sinus et cosinus
aux exponentielles complexes pour exprimer ces probabilités
en termes de sinus et cosinus.
Spécifiquement, la probabilité d'obtenir zéro est le cosinus au carré de pi fois theta et la probabilité d'obtenir un
WEBVTT
est le sinus au carré du même angle. Et ça a du sens
parce que le sinus au carré plus le cosinus au carré de
n'importe quel angle est égal à un.
Donc nos probabilités
ont une somme égale à un comme on s'y attend.
Et voici un graphique de ces probabilités en fonction de theta.
Pour être clair, c'est un graphique des
probabilités elles-mêmes par opposition à un graphique représentant une seule distribution de probabilité par exemple.
Par exemple, si theta
est égal à un demi, alors la probabilité qu'on
obtienne le résultat un qui est dessiné en violet est égale à un
tandis que la probabilité
d'obtenir le résultat zéro, qui est dessiné en bleu, est zéro.
D'un autre côté, si theta est égal à un
quart ou trois quarts, alors on a que chacun des deux résultats est également probable.
Et bien sûr pour tous les choix de theta, la somme des probabilités est égale à un comme on l'a déjà observé.
Donc on n'apprend pas exactement ce qu'est
theta avec cette procédure, mais ça nous donne quand même quelques
informations sur theta.
Et si on imagine une situation dans laquelle on nous promet
que theta est égal à zéro ou theta est égal à un demi, cette procédure nous dira
exactement laquelle des
deux possibilités c'est.
Voilà donc une façon simple qu'on peut utiliser le phénomène de rétroaction de phase pour apprendre quelque chose sur la valeur propre.
Alors comment peut-on en apprendre plus
sur la valeur propre ?
Eh bien, c'est une situation dans laquelle on peut laisser
l'ignorance nous guider.
Parce qu'il n'y a vraiment pas
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut faire.
On ne sait pas grand-chose
du vecteur propre sin, et on ne sait pas non plus
grand-chose de l'opération U.
On a un circuit pour U, mais pour tout ce qu'on sait c'est
un désordre horrible et confus qu'on ne sera pas capable de comprendre
en l'examinant.
Mais une option naturelle est d'exécuter le circuit plusieurs fois.
En particulier, on pourrait essayer de faire exactement la même chose qu'on vient de faire, sauf qu'au lieu d'appliquer une seule opération U contrôlée,
on applique cette opération deux fois. Ou on pourrait l'appliquer un nombre quelconque de fois, mais commençons par deux
juste pour voir ce qui se passe.
Eh bien, c'est en fait assez
simple ce qui se passe. En appliquant l'opération U
contrôlée deux fois, on met effectivement
la valeur propre au carré
parce qu'elle va être rétroactée dans
la phase du qubit du haut deux fois plutôt qu'une seule.
Et donc quand on pense aux
probabilités des résultats en fonction de theta, on double essentiellement
la fréquence.
Pour chaque choix possible de theta, les probabilités des résultats
sont les mêmes que si on doublait theta puis qu'on
prenait la partie fractionnaire
pour obtenir un nombre entre zéro et un.
Par exemple, si theta
est égal à un demi, alors la valeur propre est moins un.
Donc en appliquant U deux fois on met effectivement la valeur propre au carré et le résultat est le même que pour theta égal zéro.
C'est-à-dire que la probabilité
pour le résultat zéro, représenté en bleu, est égale à un, et la probabilité pour le résultat un, représenté en violet, est égale à zéro.
C'est très simple, mais on peut en fait obtenir
quelques informations supplémentaires sur theta en faisant ça.
Par exemple, si on sait à l'avance que soit theta est égal à zéro soit theta égal un quart, alors ce circuit nous révélera
laquelle des deux possibilités c'est.
D'un autre côté, on ne peut plus distinguer le cas theta égal zéro du cas theta égal un demi.
Donc cette procédure n'est pas strictement meilleure que celle de tout à l'heure quand
on avait un seul gate U de contrôle, mais en exécutant aussi ce circuit
on peut gagner des informations supplémentaires.
Ce n'est pas immédiatement clair
comment les informations supplémentaires qu'on peut obtenir en itérant l'opération U contrôlée plusieurs fois
peuvent être réconciliées avec
les informations qu'on obtient en l'effectuant une seule fois, et en fait il y a plusieurs
façons de procéder.
Par exemple, il y a une technique appelée estimation de phase itérative, qui consiste à exécuter des circuits comme ceux qu'on a vus,
avec quelques variations mineures sur eux, pour obtenir une approximation de theta.
Mais je vais décrire
ce qu'on pourrait appeler une approche plus traditionnelle, où on utilise un seul circuit quantique qui a plusieurs qubits de contrôle
qui contrôlent différents
nombres d'itérations de l'opération unitaire U.
D'abord je vais décrire comment ça
fonctionne pour deux qubits de contrôle et puis un peu plus tard on va le généraliser à plus de deux qubits de contrôle.
Voici un circuit quantique
qui utilise deux qubits de contrôle.
Le qubit de contrôle du haut
contrôle une seule opération U tandis que le deuxième qubit en partant du haut
contrôle deux copies de U.
Donc ce qu'on fait, c'est combiner les deux circuits qu'on a vus précédemment, d'une façon qui utilise la seule copie
du vecteur propre psi qu'on a.
Tu remarqueras cependant
que les gates Hadamard après les opérations U contrôlées ont été supprimés et il n'y a pas encore de mesures.
Ce qu'on va faire, c'est de
voir comment ce circuit fonctionne et ensuite on va déterminer
ce qu'on devrait faire avec les deux qubits du haut
pour apprendre autant que possible sur la valeur theta qu'on
essaie d'approximer.
Après les gates Hadamard appliqués, on avait l'état qui est
montré à l'écran.
WEBVTT
Et ça va être une façon pratique d'écrire l'état pour
voir ce qui se passe ensuite.
A zéro et A un sont des bits, et si on pense aux deux qubits du haut comme étant un registre à deux qubits,
on pense à A zéro, qui correspond au qubit du haut, comme étant le bit de moindre poids, et A un qui correspond
au qubit de contrôle du bas
comme étant le bit de plus grand poids.
Après la première opération U
contrôlée est effectuée, on obtient cet état.
L'état classique correspondant au qubit de contrôle du haut est A zéro, donc le résultat de la rétroaction de phase
peut être exprimé de cette façon. Puis après les deuxième et
troisième opérations U contrôlées
sont effectuées, on obtient cet état.
L'idée est la même que pour la première, sauf que cette fois on applique l'opération U contrôlée deux fois.
Donc on multiplie A un par deux dans
l'exposant pour refléter ça.
Et maintenant on peut simplifier cette expression en pensant aux bits
A un et A zéro ensemble comme un entier entre zéro et
trois en notation binaire.
C'est-à-dire quand on pense
à la chaîne de deux bits, A un A zéro, comme l'encodage binaire d'un entier,
ce qu'on obtient, c'est deux
fois A un plus A zéro.
Et la compréhension est
que quand on écrit Cat X, on parle de X écrit comme une chaîne binaire de longueur
deux en notation binaire.
Maintenant concentrons-nous sur
ces deux qubits de contrôle pour déterminer ce qu'on peut
apprendre sur theta à partir d'eux à ce stade.
Les N qubits restants sont
toujours dans le même état psi qu'on nous a donné au départ, ce qui est vraiment une chose merveilleuse dans cette approche
parce que comme je l'ai dit avant, on peut utiliser cet état encore si on veut obtenir encore plus
d'informations sur theta.
Mais pour l'instant, pensons juste à ce qu'on peut apprendre de
ces deux qubits de contrôle.
Pour nous aider à déterminer comment procéder, imaginons qu'on nous promet que theta est égal à Y sur quatre
pour un entier y entre zéro et trois.
En général, theta peut ne pas
être l'une de ces quatre valeurs, mais c'est un cas naturel à considérer.
On a vu dans la version originale à qubit de contrôle unique de la procédure que si on nous promettait que theta est soit zéro soit un demi
le circuit révélerait lequel c'est. Et on a aussi remarqué que dans la version où on appliquait l'opération
U contrôlée deux fois,
on pouvait parfaitement discriminer le cas theta égal zéro du cas theta
égal un quart.
Donc on pourrait espérer qu'avec notre nouveau circuit on peut discriminer ces quatre cas.
En essence, ce qu'on
fait, c'est d'utiliser la notion de problème à promesse
pour rendre le problème plus facile, de façon à voir comment procéder.
Et ce n'est pas une mauvaise idée en général. Si tu as un problème et que tu
ne sais pas comment le résoudre, essaie de le rendre plus facile.
Si tu peux résoudre le problème plus facile, l'intuition que tu acquiers pourrait être utile pour résoudre le problème plus général.
Et si tu ne peux pas résoudre le problème plus facile, tu n'es probablement pas prêt
pour le problème plus général.
Donc continue à le rendre plus facile
jusqu'à ce que tu puisses le résoudre.
De toute façon, revenons à notre problème, définissons un état à deux qubit pour chacune des valeurs possibles de Y.
En d'autres termes, phi Y est égal à l'état
montré en haut de l'écran quand theta est choisi
spécifiquement comme Y sur quatre.
Et voici ces quatre
états écrits explicitement.
Donc pour reitérer, si
theta est égal à Y sur quatre pour Y étant zéro, un, deux, ou
trois et qu'on exécute notre circuit,
on va se retrouver avec
l'un de ces quatre états, celui qui correspond
à la bonne valeur de Y.
Et on veut juste déterminer
lequel c'est.
Et la question est, est-ce possible ?
Et la réponse à cette question est oui, parce que ces quatre états sont orthogonaux.
Si tu calcules le produit intérieur
entre n'importe quelle paire d'entre eux, tu obtiendras zéro.
Et parce qu'ils sont orthogonaux, ils peuvent être parfaitement discriminés par une mesure projective.
Et en particulier on peut
exprimer une telle mesure en définissant une projection pour chaque vecteur comme on l'a ici.
Ça fonctionne toujours, à chaque fois
qu'on a une base orthonormale, et tu peux vérifier ça
par rapport aux définitions qu'on a vues dans la leçon trois
pour ce cas spécifique
si tu en es enclin. Donc on conclut qu'il est
possible d'accomplir notre tâche,
qui est d'apprendre la valeur de Y à partir de l'état qui est montré
en haut de l'écran.
Et si on voudrait faire ça
avec un circuit quantique, on peut procéder comme je vais maintenant l'expliquer.
D'abord on peut définir une matrice unitaire V dont les colonnes sont les quatre
vecteurs listés dans l'ordre.
Cette matrice aura l'action décrite au bas de l'écran,
sur les états de base standard,
et on peut écrire la matrice
pour voir à quoi elle ressemble.
Parce que V fait correspondre chaque état de base standard, kappa Y au vecteur phi Y, on a qu'en appliquant V dagger,
ou en d'autres termes V inverse à phi Y on se transformera dans l'autre sens vers l'état de base standard correspondant.
WEBVTT
Donc ce qu'on peut faire, c'est d'appliquer V dagger à n'importe quel état qu'on a
obtenu de notre circuit.
Et puis si on effectue une
mesure dans la base standard, on obtiendra le nombre Y
qu'on cherche, exprimé comme une chaîne
de longueur deux en binaire.
Avant d'aller plus loin, parlons un peu plus
de la matrice unitaire V.
C'est une matrice spéciale et
tu l'as peut-être déjà vue.
C'est la matrice associée
à une opération linéaire sur des vecteurs de dimension quatre connue sous le nom de transformée de Fourier discrète.
Pour être plus précis, la transformée de Fourier discrète peut être définie pour n'importe quelle
dimension entière positive, et on va y jeter un coup d'œil
en général dans quelques instants.
Et c'est ce à quoi ça ressemble
spécifiquement quand la dimension est égale à quatre.
On peut penser à la
transformée de Fourier discrète de différentes façons.
On peut y penser de façon purement abstraite comme une application linéaire sur des vecteurs qui peut être représentée par une matrice.
Et on peut aussi y penser
comme un problème de calcul où on nous donne un vecteur, et on veut calculer le résultat
de l'application de cette application linéaire.
Ça s'avère être un problème de calcul incroyablement important
, et il existe un algorithme hautement efficace pour effectuer ce calcul
connu sous le nom de transformée de Fourier rapide.
En fait, c'est un problème si important dans le traitement du signal par exemple, que la transformée de Fourier
rapide est considérée par beaucoup
comme l'un des algorithmes les plus importants et les plus marquants jamais découverts.
On peut aussi penser à la
transformée de Fourier discrète comme une opération quantique unitaire qui peut être appliquée à
un vecteur d'état quantique.
Et quand on y pense de cette façon, on l'appelle la transformée de Fourier
quantique, ou QFT en abrégé.
Mathématiquement parlant, c'est essentiellement la même chose que la transformée de Fourier discrète, mais on l'appelle la transformée de Fourier quantique
juste pour clarifier que c'est une opération appliquée à un vecteur d'état quantique.
Alors changeons le nom de notre matrice, de V à QFT quatre pour refléter le fait
que l'opération qu'on a obtenue est en fait la transformée de Fourier quantique.
Voici donc le circuit complet pour apprendre la valeur de Y quand on nous promet que
theta égal Y sur quatre
pour Y étant zéro, un, deux ou trois.
Et juste pour être sûr que c'est clair, on applique l'inverse de
la transformée de Fourier quantique, ou en d'autres termes QFT quatre dagger
pour faire correspondre l'un des quatre états possibles à l'état de base standard, cat Y, de sorte qu'on peut récupérer Y en mesurant.
Voilà donc le circuit qu'on
obtient en pensant à la version promise du
problème d'estimation de phase, où on nous promet que theta
est zéro, un quart, un
demi ou trois quarts, mais il n'y a rien qui nous empêche
d'exécuter ce circuit pour
une valeur arbitraire de theta.
Et si on fait ça, voici
les probabilités pour les quatre résultats possibles qu'on obtient.
Chacune des quatre valeurs possibles
pour Y a sa propre couleur, et le graphique nous indique
quelles sont les probabilités pour chacune en fonction de theta.
Donc par exemple, si theta
est égal à trois quarts, on obtiendra le résultat
trois avec probabilité un,
eh bien les probabilités pour les trois autres résultats sont toutes zéro comme on le sait déjà en pensant à la version promise du problème.
Si theta est proche de trois quarts mais pas exactement trois quarts, il y aura une probabilité non nulle associée aux autres résultats,
mais on obtiendra quand même le résultat
trois avec haute probabilité.
Donc même si theta peut
ne pas être égal à Y sur quatre, on peut quand même penser
au résultat qu'on obtient des mesures divisé par quatre
comme étant une supposition ou une
approximation pour theta.
La supposition peut être mauvaise, mais néanmoins elle
nous fournit des informations.
Et une chose qu'on peut
apprendre du graphique, c'est que les meilleures approximations ont toujours les plus hautes
probabilités associées.
Quand je dis la meilleure approximation, je veux dire quelle que soit la valeur de Y sur quatre qui est la plus proche de la vraie valeur de theta,
dans le sens du modulo un. Le pire cas possible est que theta est exactement à mi-chemin entre
deux valeurs de Y sur quatre.
Par exemple, si theta est égal
à trois huitièmes ou 0,375, dans ce cas on voit
que les approximations
un quart et deux quarts
ou un demi sont également bonnes.
Donc dans ce cas particulier
il y a en fait deux meilleures approximations plutôt qu'une.
Et on est également susceptible d'obtenir le résultat un
et le résultat deux.
Les deux autres résultats zéro et trois, qui ne donnent pas de très bonnes
approximations de theta quand on divise par quatre, apparaissent quand même avec une certaine probabilité
qui semble être juste
en dessous de 10% dans les deux cas.
Donc cette procédure n'est pas parfaite, mais elle nous fournit des informations.
Et il est notable que
quel que soit theta, on est toujours garanti d'obtenir soit la meilleure approximation
soit l'une des deux meilleures approximations quand il y a égalité, avec une probabilité qui semble être juste au-dessus de 40%.
WEBVTT
Et plus theta est proche de l'approximation, plus la probabilité de voir la valeur correspondante de Y est haute.
Et c'est une amélioration assez
significative par rapport à l'utilisation d'un seul qubit de contrôle.
C'est en fait la procédure d'estimation de
phase quand on choisit d'utiliser deux qubits de contrôle.
Et ce qu'on va faire ensuite, c'est de généraliser cette
procédure de façon naturelle, où on ne s'arrête pas à
deux qubits de contrôle seulement
mais on utilise autant de
qubits de contrôle qu'on choisit.
Et ce qu'on va voir, c'est qu'en
généralisant la procédure, en ajoutant plus de qubits de contrôle, on va pouvoir obtenir de plus en plus
d'approximations précises de theta. Et ce sera la procédure générale
d'estimation de phase.
Pour généraliser la
procédure d'estimation de phase de deux qubits de contrôle
à autant qu'on choisit, on va avoir besoin de comprendre
comment la transformée de Fourier quantique est définie pour d'autres dimensions.
Et on va aussi avoir besoin de discuter de comment elle peut être implémentée
avec un circuit quantique.
Voici la définition de la
transformée de Fourier quantique quand la dimension est un
entier positif arbitraire N.
Ici on pense à cette opération comme étant une opération sur un système dont les états classiques sont
zéro jusqu'à N moins un.
Et ici la matrice qui
décrit cette opération a été exprimée en utilisant
la notation de Dirac.
On peut aussi la décrire en termes de son action
sur les états de base standard, juste pour la relier avec
ce qu'on a déjà vu quand N est égal à quatre.
Voici donc à quoi ça ressemble quand N est égal à un, ce qui n'est pas un cas très intéressant.
Voici pour N égal à deux, et tu remarqueras ce qu'on obtient dans ce cas, c'est une opération Hadamard.
Voici la transformée de Fourier
quantique pour N égal trois.
Pour N égal quatre, qu'on
a déjà vu.
Et pour un dernier exemple, voici quand N est égal à huit.
Tout comme on l'avait avant
pour le cas N égal quatre, ce sont les matrices qu'on associe à la transformée de Fourier discrète
pour chacune des dimensions. Mais on l'appelle la
transformée de Fourier quantique quand on veut y penser
comme une opération quantique.
Parfois soit dit en passant, le facteur de tête d'un sur la racine carrée de N n'est pas inclus quand on pense à la transformée de Fourier
discrète comme une matrice,
mais on a besoin de ce facteur ici pour s'assurer qu'on obtient une matrice unitaire.
Il y a aussi parfois un signe moins dans chacun des exposants, mais pas toujours.
C'est fondamentalement juste une préférence personnelle qui ne change pas la nature fondamentale
de la transformée.
Mais dans tous les cas, on va définir la transformée de Fourier quantique telle qu'elle est écrite ici à l'écran.
Il y a une notation abrégée très utile
qui est commune et on va l'utiliser
un peu plus tard dans la leçon.
Et c'est de définir un
nombre complexe omega N, comme on l'a ici.
Spécifiquement comme e à la puissance deux pi I sur N, ce qui peut aussi être écrit
en utilisant des sinus et cosinus
comme on l'a ici. Parfois on appelle ce
nombre une racine N-ième de l'unité parce que quand on l'élève
à la puissance N, on obtient un.
Voici une figure qui montre quelques exemples.
Omega un est égal à un, omega deux est égal à moins un, et omega quatre est égal à I.
En général pour obtenir omega N, on peut imaginer découper le cercle unité en N morceaux de taille égale comme si c'était une pizza partagée par N personnes
et omega N est au
coin du premier morceau, en supposant que l'autre coin
de ce morceau est à un.
Donc en particulier lorsque N
devient de plus en plus grand, les morceaux vont devenir de plus en plus petits, et omega N va devenir
de plus en plus proche de un.
Et maintenant si on utilise cette notation on peut exprimer la
transformée de Fourier quantique d'une façon légèrement plus propre.
Parfois cette notation
aide à garder les choses simples comme on va le voir se produire
un peu plus tard dans la leçon.
Il y a une implémentation efficace en circuit
quantique de la transformée de Fourier quantique
quand N est une puissance de deux,
qu'on va maintenant examiner. Bien qu'on tende à définir la
transformée de Fourier quantique pour n'importe quelle dimension N,
on va seulement en avoir besoin
dans le cas où N est une puissance de deux, pour généraliser la
procédure d'estimation de phase.
L'implémentation va
utiliser des gates de phase contrôlés qui sont représentés comme on
l'a ici à l'écran.
Ils ressemblent à deux
contrôles connectés ensemble avec un nombre qui
est alpha dans ce cas.
Et l'action de ce gate est décrite par la matrice montrée ici.
Ce sont littéralement
des gates de phase contrôlés, ce qui signifie qu'on a un qubit de contrôle qui contrôle un gate de phase.
On a vu les gates de phase bien en arrière dans la leçon un.
Mais pour les gates de phase spécifiquement, ça n'a en fait pas d'importance
quel qubit est le contrôle et lequel est la cible.
Et on l'a vu dans la leçon deux, pour le cas spécifique d'un gate Z.
Et maintenant qu'on a cette notion, on peut passer à la façon dont la
transformée de Fourier quantique peut être implémentée.
WEBVTT
L'implémentation est récursive par nature et la façon la plus simple de
la décrire en termes simples est peut-être de donner un exemple qui
peut facilement être généralisé.
Voici comment on peut le faire
quand N est égal à 32.
Il y a donc cinq qubits.
Pour être clair, on associe les
états de base standard de ces cinq qubits avec les entiers entre zéro et 31 en notation binaire.
La première chose qu'on fait, c'est d'effectuer la transformée de Fourier
quantique pour N égal 16 sur tous les qubits sauf
le qubit de moindre poids,
qui est celui du haut. Et c'est la partie
récursive de la construction.
Donc pour implémenter cette opération, on doit suivre le même
schéma mais avec un qubit de moins.
Et dans le cas de base on a
juste un seul qubit pour lequel la transformée de Fourier quantique est juste un gate Hadamard.
Une fois qu'on applique la QFT sur tous les qubits sauf celui du haut, on applique un ensemble de gates de phase contrôlés utilisant les phases qui sont
indiquées dans le diagramme.
On applique ensuite un gate Hadamard
au qubit du haut, et on déplace les qubits un peu en utilisant quelques gates de permutation.
Ces gates de permutation ont pour effet de permuter cycliquement les qubits ce qui est nécessaire pour faire
fonctionner la construction.
On peut suivre exactement le même schéma pour d'autres choix de N
à condition qu'ils soient des puissances de deux, où on commence toujours les
gates de phase contrôlés
avec alpha étant pi sur
deux pour le qubit du bas et en divisant par deux à chaque fois
en se déplaçant vers la gauche dans le diagramme
pour obtenir les phases suivantes. Maintenant il n'est pas du tout évident
que cette construction fonctionne.
Et je ne vais pas expliquer
pourquoi ça fonctionne dans cette vidéo.
Si tu es intéressé à voir
les détails sur pourquoi ça fonctionne, tu peux les trouver dans le
contenu écrit de la leçon.
Je dirai cependant que
ce qui est exploité ici, c'est la structure de base des
transformées de Fourier discrètes
et en fait c'est exactement
la même structure qui permet à la transformée de
Fourier rapide de fonctionner.
Une autre façon de dire ça, c'est que si on regarde la transformée de Fourier rapide, on peut y penser en
termes de circuits quantiques.
Et c'est le circuit qu'on obtient.
Alors combien de gates a-t-on besoin au total pour cette implémentation ?
Pour le déterminer, soit SM le nombre de gates dont on a
besoin quand on a M qubits.
Quand M est égal à un, on a juste besoin d'un seul gate parce que la QFT est juste une opération Hadamard dans ce cas.
Si M est au moins deux, voici
les gates dont on a besoin.
D'abord on a besoin de SM moins un gates pour la transformée de Fourier
quantique sur M moins un qubits, quel que soit ce nombre.
On a aussi besoin de M moins un
gates de phase contrôlés, M moins un gates de permutation,
et un gate Hadamard supplémentaire.
Voici donc une expression
de SM dans les deux cas quand M est égal à un et
quand M est au moins deux.
C'est un exemple de ce qu'on appelle une relation de récurrence et
elles apparaissent très souvent dans l'analyse des algorithmes.
Celle-ci en particulier
s'avère être très simple et elle a une expression dite
en forme fermée, qu'on peut obtenir par sommation.
Pour être précis, la valeur de SM est la somme des M premiers
entiers impairs consécutifs, qui est égale à M carré,
comme tu l'as peut-être déjà rencontré ou peut-être que tu l'as juste remarqué
à un moment donné dans ta vie.
Et il s'avère qu'il est assez facile de prouver cette formule est vraie par induction sur M
au cas où tu serais intéressé par une preuve formelle.
Voilà donc. On peut implémenter la
transformée de Fourier quantique sur M qubits en utilisant M carré gates.
Juste quelques brèves
remarques supplémentaires.
Premièrement on n'a pas vraiment
besoin de tous les gates de permutation que j'ai décrits.
Il est possible de les pousser
effectivement tous vers la fin tant qu'on ajuste les qubits sur lesquels les gates de phase contrôlés
agissent de façon appropriée.
Et si on fait ça on aura seulement
besoin de M sur deux gates de permutation au total en arrondissant à la baisse.
On aura toujours un coût quadratique, mais le nombre de gates peut être réduit de cette façon quand même.
Et une dernière remarque, c'est qu'on peut en fait rendre le coût encore plus bas si on est prêt à se contenter d'une assez bonne approximation.
Par exemple, quand M devient grand, beaucoup des gates de phase contrôlés sont assez proches de
l'opération identité,
et éliminer ceux
qui sont très proches peut nous économiser beaucoup en termes de gates tout en nous donnant quand même une
assez bonne approximation.
Il est aussi possible d'approximer la transformée de Fourier quantique
avec des circuits très peu profonds, c'est-à-dire ceux ayant une petite profondeur, au cas où c'est quelque chose
qu'on souhaite faire.
Et maintenant qu'on sait ce qu'est la
transformée de Fourier quantique pour différentes dimensions, ainsi que comment elle peut être implémentée quand la dimension est une puissance de deux,
on peut revenir à la
procédure d'estimation de phase et voir comment elle peut être généralisée où on utilise un nombre arbitraire M de qubits de contrôle.
Voici à quoi ressemble la procédure comme circuit quantique pour
un choix arbitraire de M.
On a M qubits de contrôle en haut, qu'on suppose tous
initialisés à l'état zéro.
On applique un gate Hadamard
à chacun d'eux et puis chacun d'eux est
utilisé comme qubit de contrôle pour appliquer une certaine puissance de
l'opération unitaire U,
WEBVTT
où on double le nombre
de fois U est appliqué pour chaque qubit de contrôle.
Ici dans ce diagramme j'ai indiqué ça en incluant les puissances
sur U dans les boîtes plutôt que de montrer le gate U contrôlé
appliqué autant de fois, comme façon à la fois de rendre
le diagramme plus clair et d'économiser de l'espace pour
qu'il tienne à l'écran.
Maintenant la première chose dont on a besoin de remarquer
à propos de cette procédure, c'est qu'elle pourrait devenir très coûteuse.
En particulier on
double le nombre de fois que chaque opération U est appliquée
pour chaque qubit de contrôle.
Et si la façon dont on fait ça, c'est simplement d'itérer un gate U contrôlé autant de fois qu'on en a besoin,
on va obtenir un circuit énorme. Il sera exponentiellement
grand par rapport au nombre M.
C'est une limitation majeure en général, et en particulier ça limite notre capacité à obtenir des approximations précises
des valeurs propres.
Dans le cas spécifique de la factorisation cependant, auquel on va arriver bientôt, il s'avère qu'on est très chanceux et on peut jouer un tour qui nous permet
d'éviter cette explosion exponentielle en coût.
Mais en général pour des opérations
unitaires U arbitraires, ça ne sera pas possible et
on va payer un prix élevé
pour augmenter
le nombre de qubits de contrôle.
Je ne vais pas
faire une analyse détaillée du circuit dans cette vidéo et je vais simplement mentionner qu'il y a une expression assez simple pour l'état
juste avant les mesures qui est montré ici à l'écran.
À partir de cet état on peut obtenir une expression pour les probabilités
des différents résultats, et ça ressemble à ça.
Et une fois qu'on a cette expression,
on peut raisonner à son sujet, et en réalité cette expression
est tout ce dont on a besoin pour continuer.
Comme je l'ai dit, je ne vais pas entrer dans
les détails dans cette vidéo, mais tu peux les trouver dans le
contenu écrit de la leçon et il s'avère que ce n'est
en fait pas si compliqué,
donc jette-y un coup d'œil si tu en es enclin. Si on fait l'analyse, ce qu'on trouve, c'est que la situation
n'est pas si différente
du cas M égal deux, sauf qu'on obtient plus de précision.
En particulier, on peut penser
d'abord à la probabilité d'obtenir la très meilleure ou l'une des
deux meilleures approximations,
ce qu'on peut exprimer comme on l'a ici.
Tu peux ignorer cet indice de un sur la valeur absolue si tu veux.
C'est juste un symbole qu'on peut
utiliser pour nous rappeler qu'on parle d'approximations sur le cercle où on pense à theta égal zéro
et theta égal un comme étant la même chose. Le point ici, c'est qu'on
pense à quel que soit le choix de Y qui rend Y sur deux à la puissance M
aussi proche que possible de theta.
Et encore une fois, tout comme on
l'avait pour le cas M égal deux, on est garanti d'obtenir ce résultat Y avec une probabilité d'au moins 40%.
En fait, la probabilité est
au moins quatre sur pi carré, ce qui est un peu plus que 40%.
10 n'est pas une mauvaise
approximation de pi carré quand on est pressé.
Et c'est en fait assez remarquable. On parle d'obtenir la meilleure
approximation de theta comme fraction Y sur deux à la puissance M
où Y est un entier. Et on obtient la
très meilleure approximation avec une probabilité supérieure à 40%.
On peut aussi penser aux
approximations qui sont pires.
Spécifiquement imaginons
que Y n'est pas si bon, et plus spécifiquement supposons
qu'il existe une meilleure
approximation de theta de la même forme qui se situe entre theta et Y sur deux à la puissance M,
ce qui peut être exprimé comme
c'est écrit à l'écran.
Dans un tel cas, la
probabilité d'obtenir ce Y sera relativement petite, au plus 25%.
Ce sera en fait plus bas que ça, mais 25% c'est ce qu'on obtient d'une
analyse assez simple, mais c'est suffisant.
Comme exemple. Voici le graphique qu'on obtient quand on utilise trois qubits de contrôle
plutôt que deux.
Cette fois je trace seulement
les probabilités pour les résultats trois, quatre et cinq parce que je ne veux pas que la
figure soit trop encombrée.
Quand theta est égal à
un demi par exemple, on est garanti d'obtenir le résultat quatre.
Et donc on prend notre
approximation comme étant quatre huitièmes ou un demi parce que deux à la
puissance trois est huit.
Et dans ce cas on a exactement raison. Et tant que theta est plus proche de un demi qu'il n'est de disons trois
huitièmes par exemple,
on obtient le résultat quatre avec une probabilité plus élevée
que le résultat trois.
Et avec une probabilité,
encore plus grande que 40%.
Voici le graphique quand M est égal à quatre. Et les courbes ont l'air
pratiquement identiques, sauf qu'on a maintenant zoomé
d'un facteur deux.
Donc maintenant les résultats qui sont tracés incluent sept, huit et neuf et on prend l'approximation comme étant l'un de ces nombres
divisé par 16 plutôt que huit.
Et je vais montrer un dernier graphique où on augmente à M égal cinq.
Et encore on va
zoomer d'un facteur deux.
Et le voilà. Encore une fois les courbes ont l'air
pratiquement identiques, mais on double effectivement
notre précision.
WEBVTT
Et comme avant on obtient la très meilleure approximation de theta, avec une probabilité supérieure à 40%.
C'est assez incroyable. Mais si 40% n'est pas suffisant
comme mesure de confiance,
ce qu'on peut faire, c'est d'exécuter la procédure un petit nombre de fois, et
prendre le mode des résultats, c'est-à-dire celui qui
apparaît le plus fréquemment.
Et si on fait ça, on sera extrêmement susceptible de se retrouver avec une très bonne approximation de theta.
Rappelle-toi soit dit en passant que chaque fois qu'on exécute la
procédure d'estimation de phase on a que le vecteur propre
sort inchangé.
Donc il est disponible pour qu'on exécute la procédure
plusieurs fois comme ça.
En bref, on recueille
des statistiques sur theta, et le point est qu'en faisant ça on peut obtenir une approximation très précise de theta
avec très haute confiance, et on n'a pas besoin de beaucoup d'itérations de la procédure pour faire ça.
Et c'est ainsi que la procédure d'estimation de
phase fonctionne.
Dans la dernière partie de la leçon, on va appliquer la technique
d'estimation de phase au problème de la factorisation des entiers.
Comme je l'ai mentionné au début de la vidéo, la façon dont ça fonctionne, c'est qu'on considère un problème intermédiaire connu sous le nom de problème de recherche d'ordre.
On va voir comment on peut résoudre
le problème de recherche d'ordre en utilisant l'estimation de phase, et ensuite on va brièvement discuter de comment la résolution du problème de recherche d'ordre
nous permet de factoriser des entiers efficacement.
La deuxième partie est complètement classique et je vais seulement résumer l'
idée de base dans cette vidéo.
Mais commençons par le
problème de recherche d'ordre.
D'abord, mettons en place quelques
notations pratiques.
Pour chaque entier positif N, on définit ZN comme étant les entiers
zéro à N moins un.
Donc par exemple, Z un a un
seul élément qui est zéro, Z deux a les éléments zéro et un,
Z trois a les éléments zéro,
un et deux, et ainsi de suite.
Donc ZN est un ensemble.
Mais on peut aussi y penser
comme quelque chose de plus qu'un ensemble. On peut penser aux opérations arithmétiques comme l'addition et la multiplication sur ZN
en les définissant modulo N.
Par exemple, supposons
N est égal à sept.
On a que trois et cinq
sont des éléments de Z sept et si on les multiplie ensemble on obtient 15
ce qui laisse un reste de
un après la division par sept.
Parfois on l'exprime en écrivant que trois fois cinq est
congru à un modulo sept, comme c'est écrit ici.
Mais on peut aussi simplement écrire que trois fois cinq égale un.
Bien sûr trois fois cinq
n'est normalement pas égal à un, c'est égal à 15.
Mais quand c'est clair qu'on
travaille dans Z sept, c'est-à-dire que la multiplication
est définie modulo sept,
on peut simplement écrire que
trois fois cinq égale un.
Maintenant parmi les éléments
de ZN pour tout N positif, certains d'entre eux auront
un PGCD égal à un avec N
et certains ne l'auront pas. Et les éléments qui ont un PGCD égal à un avec N sont spéciaux.
et on écrit ZN étoile pour désigner l'ensemble de seulement ces éléments.
Donc par exemple, voici Z 21 étoile.
parmi les éléments de Z 21, dont il y en a 21 bien sûr, il s'avère que 12 d'entre eux ont un PGCD égal à un
avec 21 et le reste non.
En particulier à chaque fois qu'on
a un élément de Z 21 qui est divisible par trois ou sept, on le passe.
Il y a diverses raisons
pour lesquelles cet ensemble est spécial, et l'une des raisons, c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on a un élément de ZN étoile
et qu'on considère les puissances
entières positives de ce nombre, on finira toujours
par atteindre le nombre un,
où tout comme avant on parle de multiplication modulo N.
le plus petit entier positif puissance qui nous donne un est appelé
l'ordre de cet élément.
Par exemple, pense à l'élément A égal quatre dans Z 21 étoile.
quatre fois quatre est 16, qui n'est pas égal à un modulo 21, mais si on multiplie par quatre une fois de plus,
on obtient 64, et 64 modulo
21 est égal à un.
Donc l'ordre de quatre modulo 21 est trois.
Arriver à un comme ça se passe toujours pour tous les éléments de ZN étoile.
Et soit dit en passant, ça ne se passe jamais
pour les éléments de ZN qui ne sont pas dans ZN étoile.
Donc avoir un PGCD égal à
un avec N comme ça est à la fois nécessaire et
suffisant pour que ça se passe.
Et juste pour finir
l'exemple de N égal 21, voici les plus petites
puissances entières positives pour lesquelles ça fonctionne pour
chaque élément de Z 21 étoile,
et ils peuvent chacun être vérifiés un par un.
Et maintenant on peut énoncer le
problème de recherche d'ordre, qui est simplement de trouver l'ordre pour un élément donné dans ZN étoile.
WEBVTT
Pour être précis, l'entrée est
deux entiers positifs A et N pour lesquels le PGCD est égal à un,
et la sortie est le
plus petit entier positif R tel que A à la puissance R est
congru à un modulo N,
ou de façon équivalente le
plus petit entier positif R pour lequel A à la puissance R est égal à un.
En supposant qu'on fait de l'arithmétique dans ZN.
On croit que c'est un
problème difficile sur le plan du calcul, aucun algorithme classique efficace
n'est connu pour le résoudre.
Et comme on va le discuter, le problème est au moins aussi difficile que
la factorisation des entiers dans le sens que si on a un algorithme pour résoudre la recherche d'ordre,
on serait capable d'utiliser cet algorithme pour résoudre le problème de la
factorisation des entiers efficacement.
En fait, ça va dans l'autre sens aussi, ce qui signifie que si tu as un algorithme pour la factorisation, tu peux l'utiliser pour résoudre
le problème de recherche d'ordre.
Donc les deux problèmes sont
dans un certain sens équivalents en termes de leur
difficulté de calcul.
On va maintenant voir comment on peut résoudre
le problème de recherche d'ordre sur un ordinateur quantique
en utilisant l'estimation de phase.
Pour faire un lien entre les problèmes, imaginons qu'on a un système dont l'ensemble d'états classiques est AN.
Pour tout choix d'un élément A dans ZN étoile, on va définir une opération
MA comme on l'a ici.
En mots ce que MA fait, c'est de multiplier par A, et ici la multiplication est modulo N.
Et pour le reste de cette leçon, tu devrais toujours penser aux
expressions à l'intérieur des kets comme étant calculées modulo N,
juste pour qu'on puisse garder les choses simples et qu'on n'ait pas à continuer à
écrire mod N encore et encore.
C'est une opération unitaire, mais c'est seulement vrai
parce que A est dans ZN étoile.
Si le PGCD de A et N n'est pas un, cette opération ne sera pas unitaire.
Voici un exemple. Si N est égal à 15 et A est égal à deux, qui est dans Z 15 étoile, alors
voici l'action de M deux.
Et si tu examines cet
exemple pendant quelques instants, tu verras que ce qui se passe, c'est que les éléments de ZN sont simplement permutés par cette action.
Donc c'est à la fois déterministe et unitaire, ce qui signifie qu'en tant que matrice, MA est une matrice de permutation.
Et voici l'idée principale. Les valeurs propres de MA sont
très étroitement liées
à l'ordre de A. Et en utilisant l'estimation de phase pour approximer ces
valeurs propres suffisamment précisément
on peut déterminer l'ordre de A. Donc quels sont exactement les vecteurs propres et les valeurs propres de MA ?
Eh bien, on n'a pas besoin de tous, on n'en a besoin que de certains.
Commençons par un exemple simple.
Voici un vecteur propre de MA, on l'a appelé psi zéro, et il est donné par la
somme de ket un, ket a,
ket A carré, et ainsi de suite jusqu'à ket A à la puissance R moins un, tous divisés par la racine carrée de R
pour en faire un vecteur unitaire. Ici R est l'ordre de A.
Et je vais réserver la
lettre R pour l'ordre de A pour le reste de la leçon.
Donc à chaque fois que tu vois R, c'est l'ordre de A pour
quel que soit le A dont on parle.
La valeur propre associée
à ce vecteur propre est un.
Et on peut vérifier ça en
appliquant MA à ce vecteur pour voir ce qu'on obtient.
MA multiplie par A, donc
on a juste besoin d'augmenter chacun des exposants de
un et c'est ce qu'on obtient.
Mais l'ordre de A est R, donc A à la puissance R égale un.
Et on peut faire cette substitution.
Mais c'est le même vecteur
qu'on a commencé. Tout ce qu'on a fait, c'est de mélanger les kets mais on prend la somme donc
ça ne change rien.
Donc MA fois psi zéro est égal à psi zéro.
Donc c'est un vecteur propre de
MA avec la valeur propre un.
C'est un exemple très simple
de vecteur propre et pour en identifier davantage, rappelons la même notation qu'on avait plus tôt dans la leçon.
Omega R est le nombre complexe
sur le cercle unité qu'on obtient en prenant E à la
puissance de deux fois pi fois I
divisé par R. La dernière fois on avait un N plutôt qu'un R, mais ça fonctionne de la même
façon pour R à la place de N.
On a besoin de ce nombre parce
qu'il va apparaître dans les autres vecteurs propres
de MA qu'on va identifier.
Et maintenant qu'on a rappelé cette notation, on peut observer que ce
vecteur nommé psi un est aussi un vecteur propre de MA.
C'est similaire à psi zéro, on a exactement les mêmes kets et on les somme et
on divise par la racine de R.
Mais cette fois on a diverses phases multipliant chacun des kets.
Omega R à la puissance moins un pour A, omega R à la puissance moins deux pour A carré, et ainsi de suite jusqu'à omega R à la
puissance moins R moins un
pour A à la puissance R moins un. Donc la puissance de omega R
est toujours moins un fois quelle que soit la puissance de A
qui apparaît dans le ket.
Je ne vais pas y passer en détail, mais c'est montré à l'écran au cas où tu voudrais revoir la vidéo et faire une pause si nécessaire.
Mais si on fait la multiplication et qu'on simplifie encore en utilisant le fait que A à la puissance R est égal à un
ainsi que le fait très important qu'omega à la puissance R est égal à un, ce qu'on va trouver c'est qu'on
a encore un vecteur propre de MA.
WEBVTT
Cette fois en faisant la simplification, on va avoir besoin de factoriser un omega R pour voir qu'on a bien un vecteur propre
et que ce vecteur omega R représente la valeur propre associée à ce vecteur propre.
C'est donc une deuxième paire vecteur propre
valeur propre de NA.
On peut identifier des vecteurs propres supplémentaires en utilisant exactement le même raisonnement, et en fait si on remplace simplement omega R
par omega R à la puissance J pour chaque J entre zéro et R moins un, on obtiendra toujours un vecteur propre,
et la valeur propre associée sera omega R à la puissance J.
Donc ça inclut en fait
psi zéro et pis un, qu'on a déjà vus
ainsi que R moins deux autres paires vecteur propre valeur propre.
Ils fonctionnent tous essentiellement de la même façon, et pour les vérifier, on a juste besoin de savoir que A à la puissance R égale un
ainsi qu'omega R à la
puissance R égale un.
Il y a d'autres vecteurs propres de MA comme ket zéro par exemple, mais ils ne vont pas nous être utiles et on n'a pas besoin de s'en préoccuper.
On n'a besoin de s'occuper que de psi zéro à psi R moins un.
Concentrons-nous sur psi un un moment, juste pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi on s'intéresse à ces vecteurs propres
et ce qu'ils peuvent nous dire
sur l'ordre R, ce qu'on essaie de trouver.
Supposons qu'on nous donne
le vecteur propre psi un, on peut tenter d'apprendre
R de la façon suivante.
D'abord, on effectue l'estimation de
phase sur ce vecteur propre en utilisant un circuit quantique qui
implémente l'opération MA.
Ce qu'on obtient, c'est une approximation de theta, qui est un sur R dans ce cas.
Et ensuite parce qu'on cherche R et qu'on a une
approximation de un sur R, la chose naturelle à faire est
de calculer le réciproque
et de l'arrondir à
l'entier le plus proche. On doit arrondir comme ça
parce que R doit être un entier.
Mais on n'a pas un sur R exactement, on a juste une approximation.
Mais si l'approximation est suffisamment bonne, on obtiendra R en arrondissant,
ce qu'on cherche.
Et maintenant la question est de savoir quelle précision on a besoin pour déterminer correctement R en calculant le réciproque et en arrondissant ?
Ou en d'autres termes, à quel point notre
approximation doit-elle être précise pour que tout ça fonctionne ?
Eh bien, il s'avère qu'on a besoin d'une approximation assez précise.
Par exemple, on ne peut pas
se permettre de confondre un sur R avec un sur R plus un, ou un sur R moins un par exemple.
Dans ces deux fractions, un sur R plus un et
un sur R moins un sont assez proches de un
sur R quand R est grand.
Mais bien qu'on ait besoin d'une
approximation assez précise, on n'a pas besoin d'une approximation ridiculement
précise, et on peut montrer que si notre approximation
satisfait l'inégalité qu'on
a ici à l'écran, alors l'arrondi
nous donnera la bonne réponse.
Je ne vais pas essayer d'argumenter ça dans cette vidéo, mais c'est montré dans le
matériel écrit de la leçon au cas où tu serais intéressé par les détails.
Et si c'est la précision
qu'on vise, alors il suffit d'utiliser un nombre de qubits de contrôle dans la procédure d'estimation de phase
qui est égal à deux fois
la longueur de N plus un.
Où comme on l'avait dans les leçons précédentes, la longueur de N est le nombre de bits dont on a besoin pour exprimer N en binaire.
Soit dit en passant, si on se contente
d'obtenir la meilleure approximation avec une probabilité d'au moins 40% et qu'on n'essaie pas d'augmenter notre confiance
comme je l'ai décrit plus tôt, alors on n'a pas vraiment besoin du plus un.
Mais dans tous les cas, on a que le nombre
de qubits de contrôle dont on a besoin est linéaire dans la longueur de N
écrit comme une chaîne binaire.
On a vu que si on a
le vecteur propre psi un, on peut utiliser l'estimation de phase pour trouver R, à condition d'utiliser suffisamment de précision.
Malheureusement il n'est pas si facile d'obtenir ce vecteur propre.
Alors posons une question différente.
Supposons qu'on n'a pas psi un, mais plutôt on a psi
pour un choix aléatoire de J.
Peut-on encore déterminer ce qu'est R ? Ou tout au moins peut-on
déterminer quelque chose sur R ?
Et la réponse est oui, on peut déterminer quelque chose
sur R, au moins en moyenne.
Ce qu'on peut faire, c'est d'essayer
de déterminer J sur R en utilisant une méthode très similaire
à celle qu'on vient de voir,
mais avec une différence clé.
D'abord, on va faire exactement la
même chose qu'on a faite avant, c'est-à-dire d'exécuter la procédure d'estimation de phase sur le vecteur propre psi J.
Et ce qu'on va obtenir, c'est une
approximation de J sur R, par opposition à un sur R,
ce qu'on avait avant.
Mais maintenant on a un petit problème, parce que calculer le
réciproque ne nous donnera pas R, ça nous donnera R sur J.
Et soit dit en passant, on ne
suppose pas qu'on sait ce qu'est J, on nous donne simplement psi J pour un J aléatoire,
et on ne nous dit pas ce qu'est J. Alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ?
Eh bien, il s'avère qu'il y a un
algorithme classique bien connu qui peut nous aider, appelé l'algorithme des fractions continues.
Et ce que cet algorithme peut faire, c'est de prendre notre approximation
Y sur deux à la puissance M et de nous dire quelle fraction U sur V,
écrite en termes irréductibles, et où U et V sont tous les deux
des entiers plus petits que N est la plus proche de notre approximation.
WEBVTT
C'est un algorithme vraiment fascinant, et si tu es intéressé, tu devrais certainement y jeter un coup d'œil.
C'est très étroitement lié à l'algorithme d'Euclide pour
calculer les PGCD en fait.
Mais je ne vais rien dire
de plus à son sujet dans cette vidéo.
Le point de tout ça, c'est que si on a une bonne
approximation d'une certaine fraction pour laquelle le numérateur et
le dénominateur ne sont pas trop grands,
l'algorithme peut récupérer la fraction, et c'est ce qu'on fait ici.
Et maintenant on se retrouve exactement avec
la même question qu'avant, à savoir quelle précision a-t-on besoin ?
Et il s'avère que
exactement la même borne qu'on avait avant fonctionne dans ce cas.
Et donc choisir M exactement
de la même façon qu'avant fonctionne ici aussi.
Maintenant ça ne va pas nécessairement
nous donner R.
Ce qu'on va apprendre si on utilise
suffisamment de précision, c'est J sur R, mais ce sera une
fraction en termes irréductibles.
Donc on pourrait ne pas avoir de chance dans le sens que ce choix aléatoire de J pourrait avoir des facteurs communs avec R,
et ils nous seront cachés. Dans le pire des cas par exemple, on pourrait obtenir J égal zéro et on n'apprendra absolument rien.
Mais c'est littéralement le seul
cas où on n'apprend rien.
En général, on va au moins
obtenir un facteur non trivial de R, et si on est capable de tirer des échantillons aléatoires
et d'obtenir psi J pour différents choix de J, on peut en fait récupérer
R avec haute probabilité en calculant le plus petit commun multiple
de tous les dénominateurs
qu'on observe. Et ça ne demande en fait
pas beaucoup d'échantillons du tout.
Le résultat final, c'est que certains choix de J vont cacher des facteurs de R, mais les choix aléatoires de J
ne pourront pas cacher les
facteurs de R longtemps.
Voilà donc l'idée. Il reste à considérer l'implémentation et en particulier à déterminer
combien ça coûte.
L'essence de l'idée, pour calculer l'ordre d'un
élément A donné dans ZN étoile est d'appliquer la procédure d'estimation de phase
à l'opération MA.
Déterminons quel est
le coût de faire ça en fonction de la longueur de N majuscule, que je vais noter par n minuscule.
Voici un circuit pour l'estimation de phase. On va avoir besoin de n minuscule qubits sur la partie inférieure du circuit
pour encoder les éléments de ZN en binaire. Donc on a N qubits de contrôle en haut et n minuscule qubits en bas,
ce qui est bien parce que ça correspond aux noms qu'on a
utilisés plus tôt dans la leçon.
Pour compter le
nombre de gates dont on a besoin pour l'ensemble du circuit, concentrons-nous d'abord sur le coût des opérations unitaires contrôlées.
Si on utilise les techniques
de la leçon précédente, la leçon six, on peut implémenter MA en utilisant grand O de n minuscule carré gates
en utilisant des algorithmes classiques efficaces pour l'arithmétique modulo N.
Je vais passer les détails dans cette vidéo, mais comme plusieurs autres
choses dont j'ai parlé, tu peux en lire plus dans le matériel écrit de la leçon.
Ce n'est pas suffisant cependant
d'implémenter juste MA.
On a aussi besoin d'implémenter MA carré, MA à la quatrième puissance, à
la huitième puissance, et ainsi de suite
jusqu'à MA à une puissance qui est exponentielle en M.
Et on sait qu'on va avoir besoin de prendre M comme étant linéaire en n minuscule
pour avoir suffisamment de précision.
C'est une grande préoccupation,
et je l'ai soulevée plus tôt.
Si on devait implémenter les puissances
de MA en itérant simplement MA, on aurait des problèmes parce que toutes ces itérations de MA
entraîneraient un coût exponentiel.
Heureusement, on peut jouer un tour pour éviter cette explosion en coût.
Ce qu'on peut faire est le suivant, pour chaque puissance K dont on a besoin.
D'abord, on calcule A à
la puissance K, modulo N.
C'est le problème d'exponentiation modulaire que j'ai mentionné dans la leçon six.
Et ça peut être résolu efficacement. Et c'est quelque chose qu'on peut faire avec un ordinateur classique.
Ce calcul n'a pas besoin
d'être effectué par un circuit quantique du tout.
Donc soit B le résultat.
Donc B est un élément de ZN étoile.
Et ensuite, à la place de MA à la puissance K, on utilise juste un circuit pour MB.
Et c'est tout. B est juste un élément de ZN étoile, donc le coût pour implémenter MB
est grand O de n minuscule carré.
En résumé, ce qu'on fait, c'est d'exponentialiser dans ZN plutôt que d'exponentialiser
un circuit quantique.
Mais l'opération réelle qu'on
obtient est la même dans les deux cas. C'est juste la multiplication par A, K fois.
C'est en quelque sorte un miracle en fait. Et on ne serait pas capable de
résoudre le problème de recherche d'ordre ou de factoriser des entiers efficacement
avec un ordinateur quantique
si ce n'était pas pour ça.
Et maintenant qu'on sait que chacune des
opérations unitaires contrôlées, y compris les puissances, peut être implémentée
à un coût grand O de n carré, on peut compter le nombre total
de gates dont on a besoin.
On a N gates Hadamard, et parce que M est égal
à grand O de n minuscule, le coût est grand O de n minuscule.
WEBVTT
On a M opérations unitaires contrôlées qui ont chacune un coût grand O de N carré.
Donc le coût total ici
est grand O de N au cube.
Et finalement, la transformée de Fourier quantique a un coût grand O de n carré.
Donc le coût total est grand O de N au cube.
En particulier, on voit que même avec notre
astuce d'exponentiation modulaire, le coût des opérations unitaires contrôlées domine.
Mais néanmoins, le coût
est polynomial en n minuscule.
Il y a aussi quelques calculs
classiques requis, comme calculer les exponentiations modulaires et exécuter l'algorithme des fractions continues,
mais ces calculs
ont aussi un coût polynomial. Et en fait, ils peuvent être faits en grand O de N au cube opérations aussi.
Il ne reste qu'un seul problème, et c'est qu'on a besoin d'obtenir l'un de ces vecteurs propres.
Comment peut-on faire ça ?
La solution est en fait très simple. On n'exécute pas le circuit
sur un vecteur propre.
On l'exécute juste sur l'état un, c'est-à-dire l'encodage binaire du nombre un, qu'on pense
comme un élément de ZN.
Faisons donc ce
remplacement dans le diagramme.
La raison pour laquelle ça fonctionne, c'est à cause de cette équation ici.
L'état ket un est en fait
une superposition uniforme des R vecteurs propres dont
on a parlé.
Et ça n'est pas immédiatement évident, mais si tu calcules la
somme, tu devrais obtenir ket un.
Et si on exécute le circuit sur cet état, la sortie qu'on va obtenir
sera exactement la même que si on avait choisi J aléatoirement
et qu'on avait exécuté la procédure sur
le vecteur propre psi J.
Encore une fois, ça n'est pas évident, mais une analyse révèle que c'est vrai.
Et finalement, c'est tout. On a un algorithme quantique efficace pour la recherche d'ordre.
Il reste une très courte partie
de la leçon et elle concerne la relation entre la factorisation des entiers
et la recherche d'ordre.
J'ai mentionné que si on peut résoudre le problème de recherche d'ordre efficacement, alors on peut aussi factoriser
des entiers efficacement.
Et je veux très brièvement te donner l'idée principale de comment ça fonctionne.
C'est complètement classique. Cette partie n'a en fait rien
à voir avec l'informatique quantique.
Voici une méthode pour trouver
un facteur non trivial d'un entier positif N donné.
Et soit dit en passant, cette méthode ne fonctionne que lorsque N est un nombre impair, et ce n'est pas un nombre premier
élevé à une puissance.
Ces deux cas quand N
est pair ou une puissance de nombre premier peuvent être traités séparément.
Il y a des méthodes classiques efficaces pour à la fois détecter et
traiter ces deux cas.
Cette méthode est probabiliste. Elle pourrait échouer, mais la
probabilité d'échec sera au plus d'un demi,
et on peut simplement l'exécuter
plusieurs fois indépendamment pour réduire la probabilité
d'erreur exponentiellement vite.
D'abord, on choisit A entre
deux et N moins un au hasard, uniformément.
Ensuite on calcule le PGCD de A et N.
Et si le PGCD se trouve
à être supérieur à un, alors on vient d'avoir une chance incroyable.
Le PGCD sera un facteur de N et on peut simplement le renvoyer et s'arrêter.
Sinon, l'algorithme continue et on sait maintenant que A est dans ZN étoile.
Et maintenant on calcule l'ordre de A, ce qui est là où on a besoin d'un ordinateur quantique.
Ou peut-être qu'on a un
autre moyen de calculer l'ordre. L'algorithme ne se soucie pas vraiment d'où ça vient, mais la seule façon qu'on sache
comment le faire efficacement
c'est avec un ordinateur quantique.
Si l'ordre de R est pair, alors on calcule le PGCD de
A à la puissance R sur deux moins un avec N.
Et si ce PGCD est supérieur à un, alors on a encore un facteur de N, donc on le renvoie et on s'arrête.
Sinon l'algorithme a échoué. Et dans ce cas, on peut
revenir au début et choisir un A différent
et espérer un meilleur
résultat la prochaine fois.
Et c'est tout. Et soit dit en passant, une fois
qu'on a trouvé un facteur de N, on peut récurser sur ce facteur
et diviser par ce facteur jusqu'à ce qu'on ait une factorisation première de N.
Alors pourquoi ça devrait fonctionner ?
Eh bien, il y a deux points principaux. Le premier est que parce que A à la puissance R est congru à un modulo N,
on a que N divise A
à la puissance R moins un.
Ces deux énoncés
sont en fait équivalents. C'est la définition de mod N qu'on trouve dans les livres de théorie des nombres.
Deuxièmement, si R est pair, alors cette équation qu'on
a ici est vraie.
C'est la formule bien connue
pour une différence de carrés.
En fait, l'équation est vraie pour tout R, mais on a besoin que R sur deux soit
un entier à l'étape quatre.
WEBVTT
Et donc si on met les deux faits ensemble, on voit que chaque facteur premier de N doit diviser l'une des deux
expressions entre parenthèses,
parce que c'est la seule façon
que N peut diviser le produit.
Maintenant, il se pourrait que chaque
facteur premier de N divise la première
expression entre parenthèses et non la deuxième, mais pour notre A aléatoire,
c'est peu probable. Et donc quand on calcule
le PGCD à l'étape quatre, on est susceptible d'obtenir le produit
de certains des facteurs premiers
de N, mais pas tous.
Pour analyser ça soigneusement
il faut un peu de théorie des nombres, mais c'est une théorie des nombres assez basique.
Donc si tu trouves la théorie
des nombres intéressante et que tu aimerais en apprendre plus, essaie de travailler à travers cette analyse.
Travailler sur des choses comme ça est une excellente façon d'en apprendre plus, mais je vais te laisser ça.
Et c'est la fin de la leçon. Dans cette leçon, on a couvert
le problème d'estimation de phase, comment on peut le résoudre efficacement
sur un ordinateur quantique,
et comment on peut appliquer la solution pour obtenir un algorithme quantique à coût polynomial pour la factorisation des entiers.
J'espère que tu vas me rejoindre pour la prochaine leçon, qui porte sur l'algorithme de recherche quantique de Grover.
Au revoir jusqu'alors.